uh let's give Carl a warm welcome and uh
thank you I was just saying I'm very
excited to be giving a talk in front of
a live audience it's been years since
pre-covered since I've actually been
able to see the people who I'm trying to
talk to and uh thank you for being here
I'm going to talk about a little side
project I did called uh perfect physics
uh the project I found was interesting I
learned some things about Python and and
libraries I learned some things about
physics and I might have even learned
some things about uh philosophy the an
early version of this project led to a
hundred comment thread on physics Reddit
That Was Then banned for being too
controversial and we'll talk about how
that turned out too
so this all starts in 2015 just
generally interested in physics I
thought I'd do a project
using the Cinema 4D
modeling engine 3D modeling engine I
wanted to do Billiards and the idea was
the cue ball would hit the object balls
they'd separate and then using what I
think was a little python script within
Cinema 4D I would reverse the direction
of the balls
they would come together
reform the triangle and shoot out the
cue ball and if physics is reversible
which I thought it was then I hope that
the cue balls the object balls would
just form a stationary triangle and the
cue ball would come out at exactly the
same speed uh that it went in
so I tried this here's the uh
here's the video
of what happened
so we have our object balls
cue ball comes in it hits they scatter
we use a little script to reverse
the velocity of all the balls
they come back in
the cue ball shoots out everything's
great
except
there's still some energy in the balls
and it wasn't reversible we can see this
again from a different angle
so does anybody have any ideas what went
wrong
uh my theory was that it was a problem
with precision
that there were two problems
specifically with Precision one uh
collisions are detected on each uh frame
of the video
and so the exact position
and time of the Collision isn't known
and also of course I was using floating
Point numbers I presumed it was using
floating Point numbers
for all the uh measurements
and that that would cause things to get
worse and worse over time the rest of
this talk we'll see that I looked at
that which we could call the Precision
Butterfly Effect
and then found out that and then tested
the hypothesis that that was the problem
using the Senpai library with python
um
we'll see that that doesn't didn't
completely solve the problem
and then at the end to uh quote
Shakespeare to misquote Shakespeare that
the fault might not lie uh in ourselves
or in our code but with our philosophy
that there might actually be something
about physics that's uh thwarting us
here
so going back to the hypothesis that
it's a a measurement problem suppose the
two balls
we have two balls and they're here uh
and uh we move forward one frame
they might be overlapping now
exactly where we detect that overlap and
collision can change the angle between
the two balls and then we could imagine
that that would and that actually will
change the angle that the ball uh shoots
out another thing here is the red ball
the ball that was originally moving was
it minus 0.666666
when we started after this Collision
it's at minus three three three three
three not three or four but it's seven
just in the course of the Collision
we've lost uh one digit uh of of
precision
and the butterfly effect is the idea
that small differences can have big
consequences as time goes forward and
it's a perfectly reasonable explanation
for what the what the problem was
so to test this I wanted to do two
things the first was instead of finding
the next collision by uh frame why don't
we I mean these are just moving circles
why don't we figure out
exactly when they're going to collide
we can do that in Python with numpy by
setting up some initial conditions uh
the position and velocity of the uh
of the circles and their and their
radiuses and then we can create a
function
that says the future X position of the
first ball ball a is just the time
times its velocity in the x axis plus
its current x coordinate
so on for the y coordinate so on for the
second Circle the B Circle
um we need one more thing how do we know
when two circles are touching in my case
the two circles have radius one so
they're touching when their centers are
exactly two apart in general two circles
touch when their centers are the
distance that's the sum of their uh
radiuses
apart and we can put this in an uh
IPython notebook with some interactivity
with some interactivity
and actually put on a slider to change
the time
uh just to get an idea of what's going
on if we do that if we move backwards
they'll actually get uh farther apart
if we move it forward
they get closer whoops too far
move back a little bit
we can see somewhere around point four
point five
they're colliding
so that's better than before when we're
not
we have more Precision for the Collision
than we had before but it's not
the exact time of the Collision do we
still have this problem with the
decimals
so the
idea next was I said let's see if we can
get this to be exact and for that I use
Senpai Senpai is a python library for
computer algebra if you're familiar with
Mathematica or Maple it's similar except
it's free and it works with python works
very nicely inside python so we can set
up the same kind of things we had on the
previous slide
that were numeric and we can make them
we can do them symbolically and get an
exact answer for when for example the
two circles uh Collide the way you use
Senpai is first you define what your
Senpai symbols were going to are and
that way they don't get confused with
the python variables and then you set up
equations the first four equations you
see on the slide are just talking about
how circles move and then the fifth
equation uh
is the thing that says we want the
distance between the centers
to be equal to the uh sum of the
radiuses and that'll tell us that the
two circles are touching exactly and
with Senpai there's a function called
non-line solve because our fifth
equation here is a non-linear equation
and we just give it our equations and we
tell it the variables that we want it to
solve for time and the four numbers
about the future position
and it takes I forgot how long this
takes just a few seconds I think and it
gives us a formula
and we can find the formula for the time
of the of of the collisions
um that's this uh
does that show up that's this big
expression uh on the right
um
so it's so long it doesn't even fit on
the slide but that's okay the computer
can evaluate it one thing that might
have it surprised me a little bit when I
did this it actually comes up with two
solutions for when the circles will
collide
any volunteers about why there's two
solutions any guesses
what's that
root
oh right I mean that's mathematically
why there's two uh collisions or two
times where they touch
um does anyone have any idea physically
why there's two solutions
exactly so the two balls
will pass through each other and that's
why there's two solutions and in fact
uh
if the balls are moving away from each
other you'll get a negative time it'll
say oh just go back in time and they
collided twice because of the uh because
of the the roots that you've pointed out
if the two balls are moving in some
weird way that they never Collide
parallel but there's some other things
they could do either forward or
backwards in time you'll get a complex
solution
um I found that fascinating that when I
actually looked at the equations uh what
was going on with the math corresponded
to different interpretations uh of the
physics
so the solution I found on the previous
page is for any two Circles of any
radius is moving at any speeds but in
our particular case we have initial
conditions that give us these two
circles moving at these speeds at these
positions we can put them in and we get
the two solutions uh 13 6 plus or minus
uh uh square root of three that second
one is the point approximately 0.43 that
we saw when we were
sliding around so that's good that we've
got an exact answer that corresponds to
what the numeric solution
uh uh told us we would
um this is showing the two solutions the
two balls uh uh first hitting each other
and then some people call this tunneling
tunneling through each other and
touching on the other side
so uh to make the simulator work we need
two equation Solutions the first one is
to tell us when they're going to meet
next the next one is to tell us when two
circles hit how does that Collision
change their velocity
and we can set up uh
equations following the same pattern
that we did before so we're going to
assume perfect elastic collisions here
and the first equation just says eq1
that the energy before in the energy
after is equal this looks like three
things but it's really just one equation
just written in on three lines
another equation about collisions
perfectly elastic collisions
is that momentum is conserved and
momentum like velocity has an x and y
coordinate
in this two-dimensional case so we'll
say that the momentum in the X Dimension
is conserved in momentum in the uh
why
on the y-axis is conserved so that gives
us three equations we have four unknowns
we want to know the velocity the X and Y
velocity of both objects after the
Collision
and so we're one equation short
the final equation doesn't have a real
name that I've found but when circles
Collide
at the angle 90 degrees from their
Collision they won't speed up or slow
down so I'm calling that conservation of
glancing velocity and it's specific to
collisions between perfect circles
um and that's all equation uh four says
that that glancing velocity will will
stay the same and now we can put these
equations into simpi it runs a little
bit longer to come up with an answer but
it'll give us uh equations telling us
how to uh how the velocity changes
afterwards
so with these two
formulas when is the next collision and
how does that Collision change the
velocity we can create a a an engine so
the first thing we'll do is between all
pairs of objects we'll find the exact
time to the next uh Collision in the
topmost picture only one ball is moving
so it'll be the time for that leftmost
ball to hit the second ball
um then then we'll move forward whatever
that amount of time is in this case uh
three uh seconds or so we'll move all
the objects forward exactly that amount
and by exactly I mean we're going to
keep things in in terms of formulas and
expressions with square roots and and
rational numbers with divides we're not
going to do anything in floating point
when we move all the objects forward
we're going to have at least one
Collision but we might have more than
one Collision in that case and come back
to this we're going to pick one of the
colliding Pairs and adjust its
velocities exactly and then we'll just
Loop and the next Collision that we will
find the time to the next Collision that
time might be zero and we'll just uh
keep repeating
so yeah please
is
with number of conditions yes we'll be
talking about
we'll be talking a lot about what
happens when you get more and more
collisions it's a it's a problem
so
uh I don't want to think about that yet
I'm sorry I'll wait
thank you for asking though
um so these formulas are enough to get
us Newton's Cradle
if you remember Newton's Cradle we've
got some balls we take one out
we expect it to transfer all its energy
through the stack and then come out to
the other uh side
whoops
oh this isn't miked it's too bad
um so it does the right thing here
uh you can't hear it but it's actually
rather cute it actually does a click
noise at every Collision so that's kind
of fun
um
this also lets us do
the famous uh
tennis ball and basketball demo
if we drop a basketball on top of a
tennis ball
a lot of the energy gets put into the
tennis ball the tennis ball will will
shoot up and let's see that
this is very fun with the clicks it's
going
and uh the Precision of having
this thing be doing things symbolically
instead of uh numerically is important
here because
especially in this case where they're
getting smooshed into the wall there's
hundreds of collisions in a single video
frame but that's not a problem for the
simulator
foreign
so what's good and bad about this the
good is that we now have a perfect exact
Simulator for this uh kind of physics
thing you can use this to do elementary
physics homeworks where the answer is
you know square root of three plus uh 16
9 or something it'll it'll get those
answers correct
um the bad is the length of the
expressions for things like time and
position can grow exponentially
here's some examples on a thing where we
just have three balls moving around in a
square at first their x-coordinate is
just the simple fraction and then after
seven collisions it's this more complex
fraction and if you can read at the
bottom after just nine collisions I
think it's an expression that's so long
that's incredible so
um
this doesn't make for a practical uh
physics engine because uh keeping doing
this bookkeeping just gets so large
but maybe it's good enough for my
Billiards problem
so
let's see what happens when we redo the
Billiards now with the perfect simulator
reverse
come together
oh darn
so
it's not the butterfly effect that's
causing the only problem something else
is uh
uh is causing the problem too
and in this case we can uh
try to zero in on it yeah
isn't that disturbing
errors without minor offsets
really like that
your expectation is a symmetry that is
correct that is why my thread got banned
from physics Reddit
no no the strike ball is completely
hitting it straight on completely
hitting it straight on
um
to dive into that I have chosen to show
a non-symmetric example first
so let's take a look at a non-symmetric
example and see what's going on
we're going to have two different seeds
because I said when there's multiple
collisions at the same time I pick a
pair to change the velocities for first
so they collide
and depending on the random seed
either the two balls go out at almost
the same speed or one ball Zips off uh
much faster let's see that again
don't worry about them like looking like
they're not touching that's just a frame
thing it's calculating everything
exactly
so why does it fail well when there's
three or more objects and our formula
only does two at a time we have a
question of what order do you analyze
the collisions
I do what most game engines do and they
randomly pick among all the simultaneous
collisions
but as you randomly pick different
things you're going to get uh
the different results
and on this simple case which is three
balls one with a different Mass
I'm not going to go through the physics
here but you can see it's just little
fractions if you've had first semester
College physics or a year of high school
physics
you can work this out
when the two things Collide if you do
the assume the first one if you analyze
the first one
first then all the momentum gets
converted to the second one well anyway
I said I wasn't going to go into it but
it's very simple calculations that uh
that are easy to see that doing
the left Collision or the right
Collision first will give you uh uh
we'll give you different answers
here's a graph
showing the balls where the balls move
over time after the Collision so when
the seat is zero they've its time is
going down the y-axis here
they move according to the the blue dots
and and lines so the left wall is moving
the fastest and the middle ball is
moving slower in thus when the we have
the other seed we get the red trajectory
and the two balls are moving almost uh
uh almost together let's zoom in on the
leftmost ball
and we can ask ourselves uh
if we believe that what it came up with
was at least physically plausible and we
can go back to the equations of the
collision and see the conservation and
energy and glancing velocity are all
conserved appropriately are these the
only two solutions
that work
and in fact we can use Senpai and a bit
more work trying to find real solutions
to complex equations and find out that
actually anything that the leftmost ball
could have ended up anywhere after five
seconds along this line and the two
solutions we found well in this case are
near the extremes they're not the
extremes of every possible position so
the left ball could have ended up
anywhere here which means it could have
had a range
of velocities all of which obey
Newtonian
physics
okay so let's look at a symmetric
example now a simplified a simple one
it's going straight in I'm going to do
my game thing where I just pick a
collision first
so if I do that and do the one seed
you can see it's asymmetric which is
disturbing do the other seed
it's see it goes it's a different answer
let's superimpose those two together
and we can see them going off to
different places
if you believe that there's a physical
law called conservation of symmetry
which there isn't
you would get a third solution
which is here
but okay we've got two solutions from
kind of the game engine way to do it
we've got one solution I mean symmetry
certainly uh obeys the other laws of
physics are these the only solutions
well again using uh
Python and senpai
we can find that there's actually again
an infinite number of uh solutions that
obey the laws of Newtonian physics the
two object balls will be on a line
segments off at 30 degrees plus and
minus and the cue ball will be on an
ellipse an axis lined ellipse a segment
of the axis aligned ellipse the reason
it can't be all the way over is because
then the balls would be over uh
the balls would be overlapping
yes sorry
uh it's it is an excess aligned ellipse
in this case
you may be asking questions beyond my
mathematical ability to answer I can say
in with these particular initial
conditions the velocity of the cue ball
all the solutions are on an ellipse an
access the line ellipse
uh I mean isn't that I don't know what's
an accessing ellipse with with respect
to an algebraic curve
I don't know
um
so this
seems to teach us some things about
physics
that Newtonian collisions are
non-deterministic
which might be outrageous often with an
infinite number of possible outcomes and
it's not because of precision it's
because of something to do with
incompleteness
uh in this
condition of this part of Newtonian
physics
specifically we saw the two-dimensional
case where the balls were coming in from
either side and it depends whether we
take the limit from the left side or the
right side
um
when people say like I'd heard way back
when the Newtonian physics is reversible
that doesn't mean that there's only one
path back and one path forward what it's
really saying is that of all the
solutions that are possible when you
play things backwards one of those
Solutions is still possible
so if you make in terms of kind of
randomness of if all the random choices
you could make if you're really lucky
you could find it going backwards too
so did I make a new
Discovery in elementary physics with
python and Senpai well no of course this
stuff is already known if not widely
known uh quoting the Stanford
Encyclopedia of uh philosophy
determinism breaking models can be
constrained can be constructed on the
basis of collision phenomena the first
problem is that multiple particle
collisions for which Newtonian particle
mechanics simply doesn't have a
prescription for what happens a paper
from Berkeley Professor Edward Lee not
that long ago less than uh 10 seven
years ago who models physical systems
any set of deterministic models that's
rich enough to model Newton's Laws is
incomplete in that the set does not
include all its limit points we'll
always be faced with possible Corner
cases that yield non-deterministic
models and I made a second post to
Reddit physics with the 1D example in uh
Edward Lee's which is that example from
Edward Lee people were much happier with
that and Professor Lee actually uh
joined in the uh conversation at a few
places
so I can conclude now and we can open it
up to questions where you can ask me
things if you'd like uh with python and
Senpai we can create a perfect Newtonian
physics engine
it's not generally practical because the
Expressions get too big I think it's
really cool that we can do it at all
it's useful for some homework style
problems and to better understand uh the
Newtonian model that there kind of is
interesting things going here in the
mathematics of the Newtonian model
uh for future work uh I the simplest
thing I'd like to do would be to add uh
units so you actually know that these
are kilograms or or our pounds or
whatever uh a more ambitious thing that
I probably won't do but would be fun
would be to see if I can find always
find the full infinite solutions and
then uh project them forward
uh
resources either to play with this or
you just want to see some examples of
using Senpai everything is on GitHub
also on GitHub as of
yesterday or the day before there is a
live demo because uh Pi script will run
Senpai and I was able to Port everything
into Pi script so you can just bring up
a web page and run all these simulations
and you can change the python code on
the web page and hit enter and see how
it changes things
and there's also a four-part article
that goes into uh all of this uh on the
online medium uh
journal or a magazine towards data
science that you can look up
questions yes
yes thank you for asking that question
the question is is the non-determinism
a feature of the model or reality and
I'd say yes
it's a feature of Newtonian physics and
you can say well you had a very
simplified model what if you put in
Springs
then then it would be deterministic if
if balls were springing instead but how
are you going to set your exact spring
constant it would be super super
sensitive to that it's unlikely that you
could set it to actually model
uh
uh the real balls perfectly
um
what
okay
well okay this is a point that Professor
Lee makes if we want to talk about
what's really real the Heisenberg
uncertainty principle tells us that we
cannot know the velocity and position
of a ball
to with infinite Precision because
quantum mechanics makes that
non-deterministic
what's that
oh I would like to do the 2D experiment
for real
um I haven't gotten it set up yet
yeah I I believe I mean we in a sense
every time somebody Plays Pool they're
they're doing this they might have
attributed the randomness you get from a
pool break to the fact that we don't the
balls aren't always put in exactly the
same position and you don't even if you
want to you don't strike uh head on I
believe that's not the case my personal
belief is there's also randomness
a big sort of a big source of the
randomness from a pool break is the
non-determinism of of these collisions
that there's yeah
uh I I can only tell you I haven't
proven that so I can't say that
and under the Newtonian model a pool
break is non-deterministic
even if all the balls are done uh
perfectly and everything is symmetric
that I can say yes
no but it's very confusing because this
is three collisions uh the the question
is how does this relate to the three
body problem in physics that says when
you have three
um masses in a gravitational in mutual
gravitation
um
it's very analytically difficult to
predict their trajectory
um
I don't know that it's actually
non-deterministic it's just really
really hard but
it does it certainly has a very big
butterfly effect so the main reason it's
confusing is because when you go to look
up three balls colliding you're going to
get things about three um satellites uh
orbiting each other so it makes it hard
to it makes it hard to learn about this
because of the naming similarity and of
course three is always more complicated
than two in physics and in that in that
they have that in common
are there any other questions
yeah
so have the ball so they're not exactly
touching
correct
I believe you are correct and actually
one of my friends who's here in the
audience also suggested that
um
so the suggestion is what if the balls
and the pool break we're actually
touching what if we just move them apart
just a little bit
um would that make it so I could reverse
everything I think it would except I
can't do the experiment even on the
computer
uh and the reason is when well maybe I
could
um when you separate them a little bit
um
you usually won't get any mo any
collisions of more than two things at a
time going forward and because of that
when you reverse time there's only one
way for things to come back and things
will reverse
but even when I move them a smidgen and
it was just like uh three one hundredths
up and down and so kind of nice simple
numbers
the Expressions grew so fast
that I couldn't run it for more than a
few collisions and with 10 balls plus
the cue ball I just kind of like oh this
is going to take
you know an extra twice as much time
each time and it's going to take longer
than the time of the universe to do 10
balls I could probably do three balls
though and I just haven't done it
and just like I'm uh maybe implicitly
saying who cares about symmetry because
most things in the world aren't
symmetric symmetric
um you could also argue who cares about
things touching because most things in
the world aren't literally uh aren't
literally touching and and that would be
fair
any other questions
okay uh thank you
yeah oh sorry
oh so
not bam just the thread was taken down
as being too controversial
um I did the symmetric pool thing and
people were outraged that I didn't see
that
that the symmetric solution was the
obvious correct uh solution and after a
hundred comments that got taken down uh
the one where everything was on 2D and
started out asymmetric got 60 up votes
and everybody was was happy so I can
still post to Reddit although I'm now
being very careful about what I say and
how I say it
okay thank you
foreign